Congratulations on completing the course. We've covered lots of
material in this course and there's lots more that we
couldn't get to. Mobile web development is a huge topic
and you're probably wondering where to go from here. Now
that you understand the basic concepts, you probably have
questions about things like scaffolding and getting started, which libraries
to use and how to deploy your applications, how to
really incorporate this knowledge into your day to day work.
To learn more, you can visit HTML5
Rocks, follow Chrome developers on Google Plus,
and check out the chrome channel on
Google developers live for more information on dev
tools. There are many handy tools out
there that can further streamline your development
workflow. Yeoman and Grunt for example allow
you to scaffold and easily build your projects.